pauli hast du wolodimir selensky gestern
erlebt
ich habe ihn als einen
präsidenten erlebt den ist so auf der
welt wahrscheinlich nicht noch einmal
gibt jemand der in dieser stunde in der
stunde des krieges trotzdem noch relativ
entspannt auf mich wirkte man muss sich
das so vorstellen es war eine situation
in einem fast ja komplett dunkel im
präsidentenpalast da sind überall
sandsäcke und ich habe ihn dann
irgendwann von der ecke kommen sehen
aber relativ unscheinbar und jetzt erst
mal gefragt wie geht es ihnen ist alles
okay in kreiert und natürlich muss man
da mit einrechnen dass er natürlich als
schauspieler als jemand der tv kennt
genau weiß was er tut und dennoch diesen
präsidenten dort zu erleben der
weiterhin sagt ich bleibe hier und ich
habe ihn auch die frage gestellt was
seine familie ihm gesagt dass seine
kinder ihm sagen ob sie nicht angst um
ihn haben und nicht zu ihm sagen papa
wir stehen hier auf einer du stehst hier
auf einer todesliste von wladimir putin
und er hat gesagt nein meine kinder die
sind stolz auf mich und die sind wie
alle okarina sie bleiben hier in unserem
land
pauli dieses jahr heldenhafter auftreten
des ukrainischen präsidenten die große
internationale sympathie die er dafür
bekommt bedeuten natürlich
gleichzeitig bei solchen verhandlungen
auch ein gewisses dilemma für ihn zum
einen kann er jetzt nicht wirklich nach
geben zum anderen trägt er war auch die
verantwortung für all die menschen in
der ukraine
je länger der krieg dauert je brutaler
putin vor geht er ja auch nichts mehr zu
verlieren hat durch die internationale
isolation je mehr menschen leben kann
dass kosten und die verantwortung liegt
dann auch mit auf seinen schultern auf
see lance kies schultern vor diesem
hintergrund also die frage wie weit muss
er gehen was kompromisse angeht
genauso ist es thomas was du ansprichst
das ist wahrscheinlich die schwersten
stunden sind die schwersten stunden vor
dem für den würde mehr selensky jemals
stand und auch vor denen dieses land
jemals stand genau diese frage wie du
ansprichst nämlich die frage auf der
einen seite dieser
widerstand der patriotismus der
gewachsen ist in der ukraine und auf der
anderen seite die frage wie lange können
wir solche bilder noch ertragen aus
mario polen wladimir putin ein
kinderkrankenhaus angegriffen hat ein
kinderkrankenhaus
wie lange kann das land diese bilder
noch ertragen wie lange kann dieses land
ertragen dass tausende vielleicht dann
zehntausenden oder sogar
hunderttausenden menschen sterben und
dann wiederum auf der anderen seite die
frage kann er nachgeben gegenüber
wladimir putin und was kann er nachgeben
in einer situation in der putin zu
beginn des krieges gesagt hat die
ukraine die existiert gar nicht die gibt
es gar nicht die gehört zu russland und
das macht diese verhandlung so schwierig
und das macht es
grausam geradezu präsident dieses landes
zu sein in diesem moment denn so
landscape muss die frage beantworten und
er muss sie nicht nur beantworten
sondern er muss dann auch mit den
konsequenzen dem entweder mit den
konsequenzen des weitere menschen
sterben dass die angriffe brutaler
werden hier wo ich stehe in kiew da
zieht sich die schlange zu momentan und
die einkreisung wird enger aber auf der
anderen seite die frage wenn er nach
gewinner sagt okay wir sind wir bleiben
oder wir werden neutral wir
wohl nicht teil der nato seien wir
akzeptieren die krim für russland und
wir akzeptieren eine unabhängigkeit für
den dombach kein mensch weiß ob die
bevölkerung das mit nach thomas auf die
bevölkerung akzeptieren würde dass der
präsident auf gibt und das sind
entscheidungen ich glaube auf der welt
kein präsident auf der welt möchte
momentan mit ihm tauschen also paul was
wär deiner meinung nach ein
realistischer ausgang dieser gespräche
heute
also es wird heute keine entscheidung
geben das wird heute gehe ich zumindest
davon aus
kein ende des krieges zumindest kein
definitives ende des krieges geben denn
die lenz gedrängt ja weiterhin darauf
dass er persönlich putin trifft jetzt
treffen sich lauf der russische
außenminister und der ukrainische
aussenminister kollege aber um diesen
krieg zu beenden sind ganz sicher davon
gehe ich aus noch weitere gespräche
notwendig und
wahrscheinlich auch weiter schwere
stunden für dieses land euro und sagen
vielen dank danke nach kiew